[Music]
next is going to be danielle in
hopkinsville kentucky
hi danielle how are you hi i'm good how
are you
better than i deserve what's up okay i'm
nervous
um so we sold
a car bought a car with
cash we're debt-free other than
our home and a loan to mom
for a remodel in our house and 31 000
for our home loan at 3
interest 43 000 for
a remodel you owe your mother 43
thousand dollars
yes okay do i combine
and refinance the home and pay her off
and pay her off on a 15 year fixed yes
yes or do i go back to baby step two
because we never was in babysit two
and pay her off what is your household
income
seventy five thousand you refinance
refinance get her yeah thanksgiving
dinner will taste different when you
don't owe your mom money
especially almost 50 000 right it's not
strained
it's just i didn't say it was you know i
just don't like it i
i said thanksgiving dinner will taste
different and you know what it's your
mom so it's less strained for you than
it is your husband
yeah when sharon and i went broke
danielle sharon's dad loaned us some
money to catch up the house so we didn't
lose it in the bankruptcy
so we owed him some money and he is the
sweetest
kindest most generous man on the planet
and i my brain was about to explode
until i got him paid off
there was absolutely no strain
whatsoever coming from him
but the borrower is slave to the lender
and that does not change if your master
is nice
right and so i wouldn't have to stop our
retirement we're at 15
and i've got 12 000 in emergency funds
you're there
you've got the equity to refinance i
assume
yes it's 150 000 house we've always had
it on a 15 note yeah go ahead and put it
on a 15-year fixed rate
and let's take her out the reason i'm
doing that is is the uh
we always put a second a normal second
mortgage not a mom second mortgage but a
normal second mortgage
in baby step two or home equity loan in
baby step two
if it is less than half your annual
income it is not
it's more than half your annual income
and it's a mom loan
double reason refinance and get rid of
it
and you're it's not because we're mad at
mom it's not because we didn't
appreciate mom it's not any of that
it's a bad idea to
owe your family money that's been a
theme this hour
it is it's going to let mom be mom yeah
mom and bank
right it's just going to yeah i love
that there is no human on the planet
that can't
wonder about your vacation and what it
costs
when you owe them 43 000. or her
husband's able to make eye contact with
his mother-in-law just because he knows
i'm in the hock to her for 50 grand
it changes everything every the nicest
people on the planet it changes it still
it's the old joke is if you loan your
brother-in-law a hundred dollars and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
it
so i mean you know it changes money
changes relationship
and so the only so moms and dads quit
loaning your kids money
grandmas that are narcissists quit
loaning your grandkids money
and we had we had a call if you want to
if you want to pass some money to the
net to another generation give it to him
we had a call at a on another show dave
where
i wrote this down the the the child
said to you and i i borrowed some money
for mom
on and i'm going to pay him back it's a
mutual understanding and that just
rang in my head if you are if you have
borrowed money
sit down and negotiate with the terms
let people know here's how i'm going to
pay you back here's my plan
if if it's just unsecured if it's just a
mess the problem is when you do business
with family people don't treat it like
business
they don't right and then it gets to be
lack of communication
it's unclear we don't have same
expectations and the deal changes
right and um it changes based on a whom
and
you know what i do deals i do a lot of
business deals
and i don't do any of them except in
writing and it's partly because i forget
i forget right and i want to remember
what i said i would do
and if it's written down and you go oh
yeah now i remember saying i would do
that
i want to honor somebody else that they
happen to forget they did a bunch of
deals they forgot that
yeah i want to know what was really said
right and write it down it's real clear
right and so but don't don't loan your
family members money don't loan your
friends money
if you can afford to give them the money
give it to them if you want to
but don't want to man that's no strings
attached right that's no like
wow and you should maybe do that no no
no
no no no no now i do know one guy that
um
did a thing where he took care of his
kids first house
and in return they promised to never
borrow money again it's a good deal now
that's a fair string to put on it i'll
sign up for that deal all day long
and uh so yeah that that was a good one
i like that
and one guy said you know he put in the
will you got to go to financial peace
university i've heard stuff like that
that's not you know that's not super
manipulative it's a little strange but
it's not super manipulative
but the uh the trick is don't you know
you don't get to because you gave them
ten thousand dollars eight years ago
still
interfere in their personal lives right
that's what you don't get entranced to
and so you've got it the gift it's not a
gift if it has so many strings attached
that's right
and sometimes there's payments that
aren't payments well and it's it can be
a sneaky way to get your hooks in
somebody
and sometimes i i want to think about it
as from the receiver that ten thousand
dollars may really feel good right now
but you know you know if there's hooks
there or your dad's gonna just start
showing up or he's gonna
put on my mother-in-law is very
controlling
and she demands that we're there on
thanksgiving and she wants to give us
ten thousand dollars
it's probably not worth it it's not
worth ten thousand dollars
nope it's not worth it because you know
because she's gonna call that back
you know she's going to call back on
that and go yeah well that time i gave
you ten thousand dollars so you have to
be at thanksgiving it's like the paper
you know there's payments that's
that's exactly right and so you know if
you're dealing with a control freak or
somebody that's got boundary problems or
they're a travel agent for guilt trips
or these kinds of things you know then
you just cannot
even then you gotta really go very very
clear discussion about a gift
this is an incredible offer thank you
very much
but we need to say out loud as a matter
of fact we depend on how
toxic the situation we may even need to
write it down that there are no
strings attached or if there are what
are they
and blame us say hey a couple of hacks
on the radio one hack and dave ramsey on
the radio said it's a couple
if i'm going to take money if i'm going
to take money let's write it down
and so i just want to even a gift right
if you think there's a problem if you
think there's a problem
and so the guy that i'm talking about
this buddy of mine that did this thing
with a free house thing
it's written down it's not a binding
agreement
it's just a letter right and the kid
just promised and so
you know if they go crazy later and say
we're gonna go you know buy a house we
can't afford and go into debt after we
had a free house
uh then you know you just go you told me
we're gonna do that right and it's in
writing
right and they both signed it so you
know i mean that that's a
that that's you know you know at least
everybody knows the terms of the deal
right and uh and you can call back on
them then
but this uh this thing of i'm gonna loan
my kids money because i get more
interest that way than i would get on a
cd
and they get a cheaper rate than they
would get on a mortgage it seems like a
great transaction
except that the turkey and thanksgiving
dinner just as chewy
right you can't put a price on losing
your kid or altering that relationship
it just
changes the dressing hmm
it's not as good anymore it sounds like
taking money from the government just
sounds
nice and wonderful and clean right
they're not gonna expect anything from
us
they're not gonna want us to ever pay it
back i don't know when that would ever
happen
never here you go guys in fact we'll
just forgive your student loans oh
wait i'm just going to mail you my check
we just changed our minds again why
because we're in congress we're going to
go with an our bat on that one go ahead
and pay it all back
right my bad so i'll just pay it be
careful about taking free
anything yeah but it's it listen the
only way you can help out friends and
family
is not alone right it's off the table